A dog walker curious and daring enough to take home a smelly lump of rock he found on the beach...
...is on the path to becoming a much richer man.
Ken Willman, whose dog discovered a chunk of rare whale vomit on Morecambe Beach...
...was stunned to learn the unimpressive and smelly rock could be worth up to a hundred grand.
So as I'm walking along, she was messing about with this.
I got a bit closer, I thought, "No, it's a big stone."
"Why is she messing with a big stone?"
And then when I picked it up I thought, "That's not a stone."
And then I smelt it, I thought, "Oh!"
And I got home, I put the Internet on and Googled whale vomit, and up comes ambergris.
Ambergris is used to make perfume, and it's extremely rare.
But not many people know that except for perfume experts.
The reason why it becomes so valuable is that it starts off...
...with this sticky, liquid, viscous substance, but then over time, the waves,...
...the sunshine beating down on the sea, the sea salt,...
...these all combine to oxidize the sticky substance into a ball, into a rock.
So if you smell something pungent on a beach in the future,...
...make sure you pick it up.